Hallo Wolfgang.
Hallo Stefan. Wir sind vor dem Salon.
Sitzend, stehend, liegend.
Sitzend, seien wir ehrlich. Und wir haben viel vor.
Wir haben ein opulentes Buch gelesen, dieses eine Leben, Glaube jenseits der
Religion, Freiheit jenseits des Kapitalismus.
Es wird also darum gehen, ob wir Religion brauchen, ob wir an etwas glauben müssen.
Reicht der Glaube ohne Religion aus? Das sind die Fragen, die wir uns heute stellen.
Und mir ist dann aufgefallen, man geht ja dann so ein bisschen,
während man solch ein Buch liest, mit einer Brille durch die Welt,
also mit der Brille des Buches und lässt alles so ein bisschen dadurch dann
in einem anderen Licht erscheinen.
Und dann ist mir aufgefallen, die Religion und die Politik, beziehungsweise
der Glaube und die Politik, die hängen nach wie vor sehr eng miteinander zusammen,
wie die vergangenen Tage gezeigt haben.
Die vergangenen Tage auch. Ich dachte, du wolltest nochmal Karl-Josef Laumann
oder so das christliche Arbeiten am Werk Gottes mitschuften.
Pflichtbewusst natürlich, aus innerem Antrieb.
Da haben wir es auch schon gesehen, ja, da haben wir es auch schon gesehen bei der CDU.
Aber ich habe mir die Schröder-Doku angesehen zum 80. Geburtstag.
Hast du sie dir auch angesehen?
Nein, ich weiß, dass es sie gibt, denn ich nehme ja noch ein bisschen lesend
einen Twitter-Teil und denke mir, war ein voller Erfolg für alle Beteiligten.
Bin sehr gespannt. Du hast jetzt Ausschnitte davon, oder was?
Ja, ich habe sie mir komplett angesehen. Sie bietet keinen großen Erkenntniswert.
Es ist nicht so, dass der Altkanzler einsichtig ist. Es ist aber auch nicht
so, dass die Journalisten sich darum bemühen.
Lass mich fragen, einsichtig in Hartz IV Fehlentwicklung?
Ja, alles war alles richtig. War alles richtig.
Aber man hat ihn gefragt nochmal.
Man hat ihn nochmal danach gefragt.
Na immerhin. Ich hätte ja gedacht, dass man ihn nur noch zum One-Trick-Pony Putin degradiert.
Darum geht es im großen Maße, aber auch da schafft man es, also man,
klar will man so ein bisschen eben was entlocken, dass er irgendwas Böses über
Annalena Baerbock sagt,
aber es geht nicht darum, dass man versucht zu verstehen,
wie diese Logik funktioniert.
Also er ist ja der Ansicht, dass er sagt, mit dem günstigen Gas habe ich Deutschlands
Wirtschaft vorangetrieben, das war meine Aufgabe als Kanzler, Punkt.
Daran schließt sich ja jetzt ganz viel an, was man fragen kann,
ohne jetzt gleich in diese, sie haben Putin Tür und Tor geöffnet für den Überfall der Ukraine oder so.
Also man kann das natürlich machen, nur dann wiegelt er ab und sagt,
also hören Sie jetzt mal mein Lieber, also ja, da wird er nicht sich öffnen.
Und ich hätte es interessant gefunden, tatsächlich in eine Debatte einzusteigen
über diese Fragen, Wandel durch Handel, was ziehen wir daraus für einen Schluss,
wenn es nicht funktioniert hat.
Er fragt dann auch an einer Stelle selbst den Journalisten, ja mit Reden kommen
wir nicht weit, was sollen wir dann machen? Also wenn etwas nicht funktioniert,
also jetzt auch wenn China sich nicht weiter öffnet, was sollen wir dann stattdessen machen?
Also gehen wir dann in die Blockkonfrontation und das hätte man glaube ich gut
mit ihm herausarbeiten können, nicht im Sinne von er weiß genau wohin es geht,
sondern man hätte glaube ich da vielleicht die roten Linien von Schröder einmal
aufzeigen können, wenn es sie gibt.
Oder man hätte zeigen können, nee, dieser Mann hat tatsächlich keine roten Linien
und da wäre es hochinteressant gewesen, tiefer reinzugehen, aber hier geht es
so ein bisschen, man spielt das,
was in der Presse die ganze Zeit über Schröder berichtet wurde,
zurück oder sagt nochmal,
ja Esken hat ihm nicht gratuliert zum 80.
Geburtstag oder so Sachen, wie er darauf reagiert, naja und natürlich ist er
so souverän dann zu sagen, ja was brauche ich, muss ja nicht jetzt irgendwelche
Gratulanten hinterherlaufen.
Ja vor allem Merkel ist ja auch aus ihrem Amt gegangen als Regierungschefin
und hat die Partei damit hinter sich gelassen.
Also sie stand ja auf der Bühne und meinte oder bei Pressekonferenzen,
die CDU, die ja auch noch meine Partei ist, so im Sinne von,
ich wollte nochmal anmerken, ich habe es nicht ganz vergessen.
Dass man das jetzt Schröder nochmal unterjubeln will als Gesprächsthema,
finde ich fast ein bisschen lame, weil Saskia Esken und er, was haben die miteinander zu tun?
Also als er die Geschäfte geführt hat, war sie, wenn überhaupt, schon nennenswert.
Irgendwo, keine Ahnung, wo kommt sie eigentlich her? Aus dem Norden, aus dem Süden?
NRW, glaube ich. Ich weiß es auch nicht.
Aber eine Frage zum, weil du meintest, Schröder hätte da seine Gasdeals mit Russland verteidigt.
Meint er dann bis 2005 als Kanzler oder die Zeit danach?
Er sieht die Zeit danach tatsächlich so an, dass er dort zwar nicht mehr in
Amt und Würden ist, aber doch auch weiterhin im Interesse Deutschlands unterwegs ist.
Also er sagt dann immer, ja ich maß mir das nicht an, jetzt hier der Botschafter
für Deutschland zu sein und solche Dinge. Er wird dann auch auf einer China-Reise
begleitet, aber er sieht das so und selbstverständlich ist es ja auch so gedacht.
Also man hat ihn ja nicht da hingeholt, weil man sagte, das ist der Mensch,
der sich am besten mit dem Thema Gas auskennt, sondern diese Verbindung ist
da und deswegen wird er ja auch laufend nach China eingeladen zu irgendwelchen
Empfängen und Ehrungen.
Und solche Sachen, die in Russland dann laufen, laufen ja auch unter Duldung
der Bundesrepublik im Sinne von das Kanzleramt möchte da diese Art von Außenpolitik
über den Ex-Kanzler da anscheinend haben.
Also man müsste eigentlich mit Merkel, die Bücher kommen ja jetzt,
die Merkel-Baumann-Biografien.
Mal sehen, wir werden sie ja wahrscheinlich auch lesen.
Ja, wir kommen wahrscheinlich nicht umhin. Nun ist es interessant in dieser
Doku, dass nochmal beschrieben wird, wie das damals war.
Schröder reist, ohne das mit der Bundesregierung abzusprechen, zu Putin.
Er war aber zuvor in der Türkei, hat dort einen hochrangigen Politiker aus der
Ukraine getroffen und die Ukraine hat das also, oder Teile der Ukraine wollten,
dass Schröder eine vermittelnde Funktion dort einnimmt.
Und das ist ja sehr logisch, sich sagte, also man braucht jemand,
der einen Draht zu Putin hat, anders geht es ja nicht.
Also man kann nicht jemanden da hinschicken, der sich schon vorher feindlich
gegenüber Putin geäußert hat, dann wird Putin ja gar kein Gespräch mit ihm anstreben.
Ist kein Termin für Hospitanten.
Ja, also hat jetzt Schröder gesagt, gut ich mache das, ich reise dann dahin.
Was jetzt da besprochen wurde, erfahren wir nicht.
Der Journalist fragt dann auch so ein bisschen naiv, ja haben sie denn mal gefragt,
warum er das gemacht hat, also warum er die Ukraine angegriffen hat und dann
fängt Schröder auch an zu lachen und sagt, naja wir sind ja hier nicht im Märchen,
also ich kann Ihnen das, so redet man ja dann nicht miteinander.
Also wie miteinander geredet wurde, das wissen wir nicht.
Aber da wir ja über den Glauben heute sprechen wollen, passiert dann da etwas
sehr Interessantes in der Doku.
Es wird nämlich auch Sojen Schröder Kim interviewt.
Wir sehen sie hier auf einem Golfplatz dann stehen.
Der Interviewer will jetzt noch ein bisschen wissen, wie sie sich so verhält
mit ihren Social Media Auftritten, Instagram.
Hat sie ihr Mikrofon da oben an der Kappe?
Nein. Sie wird bestimmt geangelt. Bei solchen Dokus wird man ja geangelt.
Es sieht ein bisschen aus wie dieses rote Ding, was jetzt alle haben mit diesen
zwei leuchtenden ich nehme auf und sende.
Nein, nein, nein. Da wird bestimmt der Ton geangelt bei solchen hochkarätigen Dokus.
So und jetzt hören wir also folgendes. Schröder ist jetzt bei Putin.
Sie sind gemeinsam nach Moskau gereist. Man befindet sich im Hotel Kempinski
und sie sagt jetzt Folgendes.
Und vor allem das Foto in Moskau, das war so ein Moment.
Also es gab ja dieses Foto von ihr mit betenden Händen, wie sie dann Moskau
ist und alle haben sich darüber lustig gemacht.
Und wie gesagt, ich spiele jetzt den Clip nicht, um sie vorzuführen,
ich will das ganz bewusst sagen, sondern ich möchte etwas herausarbeiten,
nämlich diese religiöse Komponente.
Wo man hoffte, dass der Frieden kommt und dabei dann der eigene Ehemann,
also unter vier Augen Gespräch sich bewegt und dann, was kann die Ehefrau machen,
ich bin Christin und meine ganze Familie ist Christin, in dem Moment konnte
ich mir nichts anderes vorstellen.
Mich dem Gott widme und ich habe deshalb wirklich die ganze Zeit,
wo er mit Präsident Putin in vier Augen Gespräch war, die ganze Zeit gebeten,
also dem Gott, dass wirklich Frieden kommt.
Ja, und das ist doch eine hochinteressante Konstellation. Also man hat jetzt
den Ehemann, der soll das mit Putin debattieren, kann man doch diesen Krieg
stoppen, kann man Frieden schließen. Und die Ehefrau überlegt, was kann ich tun?
Ich kann nicht auch mit ins Gespräch gehen oder so, sondern ich kann jetzt nur sagen, ich bete.
Das impliziert aber, es ist also nicht nur eine Frage von, wird mein Mann überzeugend
genug sein Putin gegenüber oder ist Putin einsichtig genug?
Sondern es scheint noch, also das legt das ja nahe, eine höhere Macht zu geben,
die also beeinflussen kann, dass
das Gespräch zwischen Schröder und Putin irgendeiner Weise Früchte trägt.
Die höhere Macht. Wir haben ja schon häufiger, du hast ja initial mal Zizek
ist der große andere oder so.
Es scheint ja doch so ein paar Themen oder ein paar Einflugschneisen in diese
Art der Beobachtung zu geben.
Mir ist es jetzt auch wieder untergekommen, auch unter diesen Religionsgesichtspunkten.
So wie Sie hier, den großen anderen, den man nochmal anruft,
im Sinne von die letzte Instanz sozusagen.
Also die Außerweltliche, Innerweltliche ist alles geregelt. Man hat hier keine
Handlungsmöglichkeiten mehr. Also sucht man es sozusagen.
Wie heißt das denn? Nicht dann immanent, außer immanent? Na, du wirst es schon.
Und es war ja ein zweites großes Fernsehereignis jetzt bei RTL.
Diese komische Osterpassion da.
Ich habe so wenig Ahnung von Ostern. Ich weiß weder, wann Jesus getötet wurde,
noch wann er wieder auferstanden ist.
Er wurde Freitag, Karfreitag um 15 Uhr gekreuzigt. Und ist dann wieder auferstanden von den Toten.
Deswegen feiern wir Ostersonntag.
Ja, wir waren Freitag in der Oper, alle waren sehr schwarz angezogen.
Ich habe mich gefragt, warum und du hast mir gesagt, es ist ein Trauertag, Jesus ist gestorben.
Ja.
Gut, jedenfalls. Ich habe diese stundenlange RTL-Sache nicht gesehen,
außer so einen 30-Sekunden-Ausschnitt bei TikTok oder irgendwo.
Und die Art des Schauspiels fand ich sehr interessant, weil dort wird auf eine
Art und Weise geschauspielert, dass man sich denkt, jeder, der zuschaut, findet das bescheuert.
Also es ist einfach peinlich. Man ist so wie in so einem gut gemeinten,
aber schlecht gemachten Schüler-Theaterstück oder so. Man quält sich so durch.
Aber eigentlich denkt man, okay, wir sagen einfach danach, es war toll und so.
Und ich glaube, dadurch, dass alle von sich implizit sagen, wir spielen das
ja nicht für uns, sondern für Gott.
Also der Schauspieler nimmt nicht nur eine Rolle ein, sondern er vermenschlicht
sich selbst nochmal in der Rolle.
Er spielt überambitioniert, um zu zeigen, dass es hier nicht um irgendeinen
Text geht oder ein Programm, eine Drehbuchkreation von irgendwem,
sondern dass es mehr ist. Weißt du, was ich meine?
Ja, es ist eine interessante These. Ich glaube ja, dass es anders ist.
Also man hat jetzt nicht die allerbesten Schauspieler dort.
Manche sind gute Schauspieler, sind aber so merkwürdig dann besetzt,
dass man weiß, dass das nur Klamauk sein kann.
Ich glaube, das sind gar keine Schauspieler, die holen ja nur Prominente zusammen.
Nee, es sind schon Schauspieler auch dabei. Ich glaube, Jimmy Blue,
Ochsenknecht oder so, das sind ja Schauspieler in dem Sinne.
Also sie haben in Filmen mitgewirkt.
Ja, da sind jetzt nicht allzu viele Theaterkranten dabei, aber es sind schon
zum Teil richtige Schauspieler. Ich glaube, dass die Rezeption,
zweifach ist. Es gibt die Rezeption, die du gerade beschrieben hast,
das ist so bekloppt, deshalb gucke ich es.
Und dann glaube ich, dass es schon ein Publikum gibt, das den ganzen Tag nur
Soaps und all das guckt, das sagt, oh, das war aber berührend,
wie Jenny Elvers spielt, wie sie von Jesus geheilt wird.
Ja, aber ich glaube, da steckt auch nochmal dieses, wir spielen hier für den
großen anderen eine Rolle.
Ja, man macht das schon auch Gott zu Ehre, das Ganze. Also RTL macht das jetzt
nicht aus Frömmigkeit, aber so an sich könnte das so ein, es hat ja auch das
Gemeinschaftsstiftende, was dann bei Twitter auch passiert,
dass man doch es fast geschafft hat von RTL in so profanierten Zeiten nochmal
den großen Anderen wirklich spürbar zu machen.
Ja, also von mir diese zwei Fragen. Zum einen, für wen spielen sie?
Ich glaube, Ich glaube, es ist auch so eine Ehrfurcht vor dem großen Anderen,
der genauso gut der große Rächer sein könnte. Also gibt man sich besonders Mühe.
Und meine Vermutung ist auch, zweitens zum Thema Religion, so profan sind die
Zeiten dann gar nicht bei den Einzelnen zu Hause.
Ich glaube auch nicht. Viele schauen das doch mit voller Innenbrunst und sind
auch in der Zuschauerrolle.
Vor dem großen Anderen. Und sie fühlen sich verpflichtet, jetzt besonders andächtig,
dieses RTL-Programm zu schauen.
Ich glaube, RTL hat da einen besonderen Log-In-Effekt geschaffen über diese Bande.
Wir haben ja auch gesehen, wie Lisa und Lena an so einer Freikirche da getaucht
wurden und was das für ein Happening ist und so weiter.
Ich glaube, da hat man sich nochmal fremder Mächte bedient.
Ja, ich glaube, die Rückkehr des Religiösen oder des Glaubens,
das ist etwas, was RTL rechtzeitig erkannt hat.
Und ja, es gibt die, die das ironisch gucken, die das auch als Trash-TV einfach
rezipieren, aber dass es auch von einem Publikum so ernsthaft rezipiert wird,
wie es vielleicht nicht gemeint ist von den Machern, das ist definitiv so und
ich denke auch, dass diese Art.
Des Fernsehmachens noch zunehmen wird.
Also in anderen Ländern haben wir das, man muss sich ansehen,
zum Beispiel in lateinamerikanischen Ländern bei Telenovelas,
wie präsent da der Glauben ist.
Das ist jetzt hier natürlich selten anzutreffen. Da geht man nur in eine Kirche,
wenn man geheiratet wird, aber sonst findet eigentlich Gott nicht statt.
Das könnte aber auch sich sehr bald ändern.
Also ich bin auch nicht der Ansicht, dass wir,
so ein völliges Verschwinden der Religion erleben, also sicherlich ein Wegbröckeln
der Institutionen und da kann man ja auch sagen, das war ja eigentlich immer
und ich sage das als Protestant, der aus der Kirche ausgetreten ist,
der Versuch gerade der evangelischen Kirche zu sagen,
ja wir machen jetzt nicht Nicht so steif, wurde dann immer gesagt.
Wir machen mal so mit Mitmachen und Spielen im Altarraum und so weiter.
Und dabei kamen meistens Stücke heraus, die noch wesentlich schlechter waren
als das, was RTL uns präsentiert hat.
Und ich spreche aus Erfahrung. Ich habe Schlimmes dort erleben müssen.
Und damals habe ich eigentlich schon in Kindertagen als Theaterkritiker auf
das Ganze geblickt und habe gesagt, nee, gut ist das nicht.
Ist ja auch eine Frage des Budgets. RTL hat nun mal mehr Budget.
Und das ist ja genau die Sache. Das ist ja wie wenn man von Lehrern abverlangt,
sie sollen die tollste Show machen. Da muss man sagen, ja.
Und Lehrer können aber nicht jeden Tag Wetten, dass veranstalten,
ihnen fehlt die Zeit und das Budget dafür.
Und ähnlich ist es auch bei den Kirchen, wenn man doch eigentlich nur 50 Kopierblätter
und drei Klarsichtfolien zur Verfügung stehen hat, dann kann man auch nicht die große Show machen.
Wird aber immer wieder Versuch unternommen, deswegen da vielleicht ein bisschen
Abstand nehmen von der Show. Was ja hier bei Sojen Schröder-Kim auch mitschwingt
ist, also Gott regiert mit rein.
Das ist ja eine ganz interessante Auffassung, die wir hier haben,
dass also offenbar da, wo die Ausnahmesituation da ist, wo die Entscheidungen getroffen werden,
dass da eine Sphäre ist, in der auch die Entscheider nicht ganz selbst entscheiden,
sondern nochmal Gott mit Einfluss hat.
Es gibt ja, wenn ich das gerade noch anführen darf, von Churchill wie von Kennedy
diese Überlegung, wann fällt man eigentlich eine Entscheidung und wie fällt man die?
Und dann sagen eigentlich beide sehr klar, ja man hat alle Informationen und
dann gibt es aber so einen Moment der Entscheidung, dieses dezisionistische
Moment, wo man eigentlich losgelöst ist wiederum von allem.
Also was sehr nah an das kommt, was Karl Schmitt sagt.
Und das ist tatsächlich so eine Auffassung, die wir hier finden und auch das
ist ja zurückgekehrt im juristischen und politologischen Diskurs.
Also ich empfehle da sehr dazu dieses Buch von Horst Dreyer,
Staat ohne Gott, wo er dieses ideengeschichtlich nachzeichnet,
aber auch sagt, wie problematisch es wird, sobald man sagt,
wir brauchen doch wieder Gott irgendwo im Staat.
Ja, also diese Zeit, in der man voller Überzeugung geglaubt hat,
dass Gott immer mit im Raum ist.
Fällt ja interessanterweise zusammen mit einer Szenerie, wie wir sie hier haben,
dass nämlich sie stellvertretend für die ganze Welt weiß, da drin wird gerade
das Schicksal der Welt verhandelt, im Gespräch von zwei Männern.
Das ist also spätes Mittelalter bis Neuzeit,
die Welt ist schon so ein bisschen organisiert, aber am Ende sind es noch die
schon gewählten, aber weltlichen Führer der Welt, die im Gespräch einfach klären,
ob jetzt Krieg ist oder nicht.
Und interessanterweise konnte ja die Welt dann irgendwann durch Buchdruck und
so weiter so eine Hypermodernisierung erfahren, die also bedeutet,
die Entscheidung wird auch mitgeprägt von Archivmaterial,
das uns wissenschaftlich aufbereitet wird, wir haben dann Beschlussvorlagen,
es muss in Organisationen erklärt werden, was hier entschieden wurde und so weiter.
Also man hat eigentlich die Interaktion im Raum zwischen zwei mächtigen Leuten
immer weiter entmächtigt, sozusagen.
Und dann gibt es dieses hochinteressante Kapitel, ich habe es ja schon häufiger
erwähnt, Funktionen und Folgen formaler Organisation.
Also Niklas Luhmann kommt gerade so aus diesem Verwaltungsbereich,
ich bin hier Jurist und so weiter und mache mir aber soziologische Gedanken.
Schreibt dann also ein organisationssoziologisches Buch. Buch.
25 Kapitel oder so. Und immer betont er die Bedeutung der Organisation mit allen
modernen Sachen seit dem Buchdruck, die ich gerade schon versucht habe so anzumühen
und gibt es ja noch tausend mehr.
Und dann gibt es dieses 21. Kapitel Eigenrechter Situation.
Und das kann man auch so lesen, dass man dann einfach einen Text hat,
in dem drinsteht, dass mit der Organisation, mit dem Archiv,
mit dem wissenschaftlichen Dienst, mit den Entscheidungsgrundlagen,
mit den Hierarchien, mit dem was auch immer, Rechtfertigung,
mit mit dem juristischen Rahmen drumherum. Alles schön und gut.
Wenn die Interaktion läuft, läuft die Interaktion.
Und dann hat sie ein Eigenrecht. Egal, was drumherum ist.
Und manchmal fallen wir einfach in diese Vormoderne wieder zurück. Und hier eben auch.
Wir wissen einfach, Putin hängt da jahrelang in seiner Corona-Depression rum.
Wird auch nochmal gesagt, Schröder musste sich vorher testen.
Ja, genau, sowas. Also Schröder hat sowieso null Kontakt zu niemanden.
Und wenn, dann an diesem ewig langen Tisch und so weiter und so fort. und dann Schröder als,
Counterpart, der irgendwie so halb entsandt von der westlichen Welt,
man hat ihn nicht richtig geschickt, aber man hat auch nichts dagegen,
irgendwie sitzen alle gerade da und hoffen und beten, so, also auch in den europäischen
Regierungszimmern und alle wissen, okay, jetzt kommt es darauf an,
wie dieses Gespräch verläuft, verstehen sie sich oder nicht,
kennen sie sich noch oder nicht, haben sie gerade gut gegessen und gute Laune
oder nicht, gelingt der Scherz oder nicht, ist er taktvoll genug oder nicht
und dieses Zurückgeworfensein auf ähm,
So vormoderne, nicht aktuelle Verhaltensmodi, da ist es folgerichtig,
dass einfach die ganze Welt daneben sitzt und sagt, ja hoffen und beten halt.
Ja und wo geht man auch zum Beten hin, nämlich in die Kirche und Schröder hat
in Hannover einer Kirche ein Fenster, das gestaltet wurde von Markus Lüppertz gespendet,
das hat dann im Zuge des Krieges in der Ukraine für viel Furore gesorgt.
Wurde es schon ausgebaut?
Ja, ja, man wollte das Geld nicht annehmen.
Aber das Fenster war schon drin und dann hat man es wieder ausgebaut?
Nein, man hat es nicht ausgebaut. Nein, das Fenster ist da.
Nein, das Fenster ist da und es gab eine Eröffnung mit Markus Lüppertz,
Schröder und Petra Bahr.
Sie ist Regionalbischöfin in Hannover und hält jetzt eine Predigt und Schröder eine Standpauke.
So, wir sind also jetzt in der Kirche und hören jetzt einen Auszug aus dieser
Predigt und da sehen wir jetzt,
wie das Religiöse in diesen Kriegsdiskurs einzieht und ich finde das eigentlich
unfassbar, was man da so hört, beziehungsweise es hat mich auch wieder bestätigt
in meinem Kirchenaustritt.
Darf man Schröders Geschenk noch annehmen als Kirche?
Teufel haben in Butscher gewütet, jener Stadt, die Symbol wurde für den Krieg
Russlands gegen die Ukraine, wo der blanke Vernichtungswille sich in bestialischer
Gewalt gegen Frauen, Kinder, Alte zeigte.
Und ich sehe diese Menschen in diesem blutigen Gerippe, wie sie sich mit dem
Christusbild übereinander schieben.
Teufel haben in Butscher gewütet. gebütet. Nee, das waren Menschen.
Und das waren Soldaten, die von Putin dorthin geschickt wurden.
Und es gibt eine individuelle Verantwortung der Soldaten und es gibt die Verantwortung,
die bei Putin liegt. Aber das hat mit dem Teufel nichts zu tun.
Und jetzt kann man nicht sagen, das ist so eine Metapher, wie man sagt,
das sind aber zwei Teufel da.
Sondern sie ruft hier in der Kirche als Bischöfin natürlich das Böse auf und
sagt dann auch gleich die Opfer, die wie...
Und verschmelzen mit dem Antlitz Christi, das von Lüppertz da gemalt wurde für das Kirchenfenster.
Also dass man da auch nochmal sie in diese Art der Leidenstradition stellt,
finde ich eine solche Aufladung eines real zu betrachtenden geopolitischen Konflikts,
also das ist noch viel unaufgeklärter oder das ist unaufgeklärt.
Im Gegensatz zu jetzt so einer Schröder Kim, die da sagt, ja was sollte ich
tun, ich habe gebetet, ich bin Christin, das kann man nachvollziehen.
Aber hier das ist eine solche merkwürdige Überlagung, weil daraus abzuleiten ist natürlich alles.
Dann ist nämlich das nicht nur ein Krieg, der zu führen ist oder sollen wir
Waffen liefern oder nicht, sondern dann ist es wirklich unsere Mission.
Also dann sind wir tatsächlich in der Nachfolge Christi, ist es unsere Mission
und dann gibt es auch wieder gerechte Kriege und all das.
Also ich meine, wenn es der Teufel war, der da gewütet ist, dann sind ja alle
Menschen entschuldigt. Also was sollen wir denn gegen den Teufel tun?
Ja, im Prinzip schon.
Dann müssen wir halt auf Gott hoffen. Dann setzen wir uns alle nur noch hin
und hoffen einfach, dass es gut geht.
Ja, oder man sagt dann, und wir sind die einzig wahren Vertreter Gottes oder
wir wissen, wie Gottes Wille zu vollziehen ist und deswegen müssen wir jetzt
alle in diesen heiligen Krieg ziehen.
Also wenn wir, sobald man in diese Überlegungen kommt, von Teufeln auf der einen
Seite und denen, die verschmelzen mit dem Christusbild, dann ist man eigentlich
im Modus des heiligen Krieges angekommen.
Also da braucht man sich auch nicht mehr rausreden, dann ist das so,
dann kann man sagen, ja das möchte ich gern so haben, ich sag dann für mich, ich nicht.
Aber man kann nicht so tun, als wäre das noch mit so einer normalen geopolitischen
Betrachtungsweise oder mit moderner Rechtsstaatlichkeit zu verbinden.
Ja, also da kommt mir gerade Baerbocks Wort ins Ohr, sie hat ja kürzlich auch
davon gesprochen, dass Gaza die Hölle auf Erden ist.
Und das entschuldigt sie ja auf dieselbe Weise so ein bisschen.
Es ist halt die Hölle. Was sollen wir schon gegen die Hölle tun?
Dass das dort recht profan innerweltliche politische Sachen sind,
die da hingeführt haben.
Ja.
Während man selber die ganze Welt verliert, also den ganzen globalen Süden und
die Jugend an der Stelle, finde ich auch, kann man zwar zum einen sagen,
oh, das ist aber krass, Baerbock hat endlich deutliche Worte gefunden,
aber wir können leider politisch mit keiner Handlungslogik daran anschließen,
weil die Hölle halt, also ein kleiner Kategorienfehler.
Da kann ich ja nicht eingreifen. Und es ist gut, dass du Gase ansprichst,
denn wir hören uns jetzt die gesamte Osteransprache von Olaf Scholz an,
keine Sorge, sie ist nur 100 Sekunden lang. Eine Minute und 45.
Okay.
Und wir hören dann nach noch eine andere Osteransprache, denn das ist wohl jetzt
sowas Neues, man hat nicht nur Weihnachtsansprachen und Silvesteransprachen,
sondern jetzt gibt es auch noch Osteransprachen.
Und zwar nicht nur von Olaf Scholz, sondern auch vom eigentlichen Kanzler der
Herzen oder wie soll man ihn bezeichnen?
Das ist ja eigentlich.
Robert Habeck.
Ja.
Hat auch eine große Osterbotschaft.
Genau, das ist ganz interessant. Also, die haben ja alle wöchentliche Podcasts.
Der Kanzler, wie die Kanzlerin vorher, die hatten ja wöchentliche Podcasts.
So, es hieß dann immer, ja Merkel ist ja nirgendwo zu hören und sie äußert sich nicht und so.
Und dann macht sie einmal dieses, es ist ernst, also nehmen sie es ernst,
einmal in zehn Jahren irgendwas.
Und das ist ja eigentlich interessant, dass wir Politiker haben,
denen wir die ganze Zeit unterstellen, sie kommunizieren ja gar nicht.
Dabei haben die wöchentliche Podcast. Also man kann ihnen zuhören.
Und dann erfindet man aber Termine, wo es heißt, naja, jetzt müssen sie zuhören.
Das ist jetzt nicht nur der wöchentliche Podcast.
Und worauf basiert man diese Unterstellung, dass jetzt aber alle zuhören?
Einen christlichen Kalender. Ja, das ist absurd. Das ist eigentlich verrückt.
Vor allem, wenn wir uns jetzt anhören, was der Kanzler sagt.
Also wir wissen jetzt Ostern, wir feiern die Wiederauferstehung von den Toten
und wir bekommen damit als Christen die Botschaft gesendet, das Leben ist nicht das Ende,
danach geht es weiter, dann ist das ewige Leben da.
Ja und man kann jetzt fragen, was soll die Politik in diesem Rahmen sagen?
Ich würde behaupten besser nichts, aber Schröder, Scholz äußert sich hier und
wir achten auch mal darauf, wo der Schwerpunkt liegt, er liegt nämlich nicht bei Gaza.
Kaum etwas hat unsere Welt so nötig wie Frieden. In den Ostergottesdiensten
an diesem Wochenende beten Christinnen und Christen weltweit für eine friedlichere Welt.
Nach dem furchtbaren Terrorangriff der Hamas auf Israel herrscht Krieg im Nahen
Osten mit fürchterlichen Folgen für so viele Unschuldige.
Und seit mehr als zwei Jahren schon leiden die Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer unter
Russlands brutalem Angriff.
Sie wünschen sich nichts sehnlicher als Frieden. Wir alle sehnen uns nach einer friedlicheren Welt.
Aber das ist auch wahr. Frieden ohne Freiheit heißt Unterdrückung.
Frieden ohne Gerechtigkeit gibt es nicht. Deshalb unterstützen wir die Ukraine
in ihrem Kampf für einen gerechten Frieden, solange wie das nötig ist.
Wir tun das auch für uns, für unsere Sicherheit.
Der Frieden in Europa beruht seit vielen Jahrzehnten auf einem ganz zentralen Prinzip.
Dieses Prinzip hat Putins Russland gebrochen. Aber wir haben es in der Hand,
diesem Prinzip wieder Geltung zu verschaffen.
Indem wir eben die Ukraine weiter unterstützen, entschlossen und besonnen.
Indem wir mehr in unsere eigene Sicherheit investieren. Indem wir als Land zusammenhalten,
statt uns auseinanderbringen zu lassen.
Zumal uns doch die Überzeugung verbindet, dass das Recht sich durchsetzen muss gegen die Gewalt.
Das ist die Voraussetzung für Frieden, gerade in diesen Tagen.
Ich wünsche Ihnen und Ihren Familien und Freunden auch in dieser schwierigen
Zeit schöne Feiertage. Frohe Ostern.
Ja, wir bekommen also Gaza nicht mal als Wort erwähnt, sondern da sind Opfer
beim Krieg in Nahost und das reicht und dann wird sofort zur Ukraine geschwingt.
Man redet hier vom gerechten Frieden, also das ist jetzt das Pronomen zum gerechten Krieg.
Es gibt keinen Frieden ohne Gerechtigkeit. Finde ich ein bisschen krass,
weil nur weil Frieden herrscht, also Gewaltlosigkeit im großen Maßstab,
heißt das doch nicht, dass es gerecht zugeht, oder?
Überhaupt nicht.
Das ist ja irgendwie.
Überhaupt nicht. So ein bisschen. Man müsste ja auch dann definieren,
was wäre Gerechtigkeit.
Also dann müsste man sagen, also gerecht wäre es, wenn die Ukraine die Krim
zurückbekommt und bei Donbass ist das so und so und so und dann kann man das
so ein bisschen ausbuchstabieren und dann sagt man, dann ist Gerechtigkeit,
dann ist ein gerechter Friede.
Also das einfach so dahin zu sagen, bringt ja relativ wenig.
Und es ist doch erstaunlich, dass also eine Osteransprache, die es sonst so
eigentlich nicht gibt, vom Kanzler genutzt wird, um zu sagen,
wir müssen jetzt weiterhin die Ukraine unterstützen. unterstützen.
Und jetzt kommt Vizekanzler Habeck.
Bevor wir haben gesehen, also in diesem, ich will nur kurz anmerken,
AI-Zeitalter, ist Scholz wirklich die Vorlage.
Also das ist ja wirklich synthetisiert, noch auf Kohlenstoffbasis,
aber das ist ja wirklich, ich glaube man kann gar nicht mehr so schlecht es
replizieren, dass man es nicht als,
Duplikat des echten Auftritts da sieht. So wie er da steht und überhaupt.
Der Tonfall, diese Monotonie, das ist ja die Variation in der Stimmhöhe und
so. Also du brauchst ja wirklich,
Wozu diese ganzen großen Versuche, da Technik zu schaffen, die irgendwas,
ja was denn, die Vorlage ist doch keine Herausforderung.
Ja, ich denke, AI wird es menschlicher machen.
Habeck könnte ja jetzt über vieles reden, zum Beispiel darüber,
dass es eine Gemeinschaftsdiagnose der Wirtschaftsinstitute gab mit großer Pressekonferenz.
Die wirtschaftliche Lage ist angeschlagen, hieß es da, die Produktivität tritt
auf der Stelle, Wirtschaftswachstum 0,1 Prozent, nächstes Jahr 0,4 Prozent, also auch so gut wie nix.
Und es gäbe Grund, darüber zu reden als Wirtschaftsminister,
auch darüber, dass, ich habe mal ein bisschen geguckt in der europäischen Presse,
dank Diepel kann man sich ja alles gut zugänglich machen,
wenn dann in El Pais ein Riesenartikel erscheint, also der spanischen großen
Tageszeitung, wie problematisch die Wirtschaft von Deutschland ist und dass
die jetzt so Rechnungen machen,
wie die europäische Wirtschaft wächst, wenn man mal Deutschland ausklammert und solche Dinge.
Es gäbe wirklich sehr viel, worüber man vielleicht als Wirtschaftsminister reden könnte.
Nein, Habeck nutzt die Zeit um zehn Minuten lang, keine Sorge,
wir hören das nicht komplett, um zehn Minuten lang seine Osterbotschaft,
die da lautet, wir müssen die Ukraine unterstützen, an die Leute zu bringen.
Er erwähnt mit keinem Wort den Krieg in Nahost, aber wir hören mal rein. Nein.
Wir feiern Ostern. Hoffentlich für viele von euch ein paar Tage der Ruhe zum
Durchschnaufen und die Dinge sortieren zu können.
Ich wusste auch gar nicht, dass wir per Du sind.
Ja, das ist hier das ist alles orientiert an Pistorius.
Ja.
Irgendwas ist passiert. Nein, jetzt heißt es Kurs halten, Bahnen ziehen,
dann werden die ganzen Floskeln wirklich, das ist im Grunde gibt man das dem
Prompt mit, wenn man diesen Text generieren lässt, bitte diese Art von Floskelei.
Glauben ist Ostern das Fest der
Auferstehung, der Hoffnung, Hoffnung auf Frieden, auf eine erlöste Welt.
Ostern 2024 sind wir weit vom Frieden entfernt.
Putins Krieg gegen die Ukraine ist der blutigste, den Europa seit 1945 erlebt hat.
Jeder Tag ist ein Tag des Sterbens und ein Ende ist nicht in Sicht.
Ja, also ist eigentlich eine Friedensbotschaft Ostern.
Wer Ostern kennt, kann nicht verzweifeln, sagt Dietrich Bonhoeffer,
ja in diesem Modus sind wir, aber wir haben jetzt hier schon ganz klar gesagt
bekommen, in welche Richtung es geht, also um die Unterstützung der Ukraine
aus der Osterbotschaft heraus.
Also man sagt ja nicht einfach, ich sag jetzt was zur Ukraine,
sondern man nimmt die Osterbotschaft und führt die dann weiter,
so nach dem Motto, denn auch Jesus ist für die NATO gestorben.
Ich will jetzt nicht so haarspalterisch werden, aber er meinte,
das ist der blutigste Krieg, den Europa jetzt sieht.
Laut Zelensky sind 30.000 ukrainische Soldaten gestorben.
Wir vermuten, dass es weit mehr sind, aber die offizielle Zahl sagt 30.000.
Das bedeutet, laut UN-Angaben sind in Gaza mehr Menschen gestorben. Auf Opferseite.
In kürzerer Zeit. damit qualifiziert sich die Aussage das ist der blutigste
Krieg nicht also ist dann einfach auch sachlich falsch und da muss man überlegen,
wenn man ihn jetzt hier so sieht,
wie er die Augen zusammenkneift und seine Habeck Stimme auflegt das findet ja ein Publikum,
aber und das muss man heute einpreisen es findet auch ein Antipublikum also
in dem Moment, wo Habeck so kommuniziert,
holt er Leute zu sich, aber er stößt auch welche weg.
Und das muss man ja immer mitbetrachten und austarieren, gerade wenn man wie
ein Politiker auf Stimmfang ist für die nächste Wahl.
Also Stimmfang mal, ganz despektierlich ausgedrückt.
Und ich würde hier bei solchen Sachen, wenn ich einen Beraterstab habe,
wäre, beispielsweise als Populismusbeauftragter der Grünen,
nochmal allen ins Gewissen reden, zieht eine Bilanz vorher, was ihr glaubt,
wie viele Leute gewinnt ihr und wie viele Leute verliert ihr durch diese Kommunikation.
So wie man bei uns ja auch spürt, dass es jetzt nicht um den Gewinn bringt,
ist für Habit, wenn wir sowas hören.
Das ist Preaching to the Choir. Und dieser Choir ist relativ klein.
Wir könnten sie jetzt namentlich alle aufrufen.
Noch einen anderen Choir. Ich glaube auch. Mittlerweile, die verwechseln.
Also ich sage ja häufiger, man übersieht immer wieder, wie groß Deutschland
ist. Und ich glaube, das ist hier auch der Fall.
Ja, es gibt so etwa 50 Journalisten, die bei Twitter wirklich ausflippen vor
Freude, wenn so ein Video kommt und sagen, eigentlich ist er der Kanzler.
Und sonst war es das. Und ganz ehrlich, wenn Politiker, also ich habe schon
mal kritisiert, ich mag es nicht, wenn infantil mit mir gesprochen wird.
Wenn Politiker oder MIT oder andere mit mir sprechen, als sei ich sieben Jahre
alt, Dann habe ich grundsätzlich in mir eine Abwehr gegen das Gehörte.
Und genauso ist es auch, sobald jemand mit mir kommt und mir eine Predigt hält.
Dann geht das so weit, dass Habeck in dem Video sagen könnte,
wir alle wissen, 2 plus 2 ist 4 und dann würde ich sagen, nee, ist 5.
Er verliert uns.
Also diese Art, und er verliert uns aber jetzt auch faktisch,
wenn wir jetzt Folgendes hören.
So sehr ich verstehe, dass angesichts der hohen Opferzahlen von einem Einfrieren
des Krieges gesprochen wird, so sehr blendet diese Position aus,
dass nur die Ukrainerinnen und Ukrainer entscheiden können, welchen Preis sie
zu zahlen bereit sind und zu welchen Bedingungen sie einen Waffenstillstand
erreichen oder den Krieg beenden wollen.
Es sind die ukrainischen Väter, Söhne und Brüder, die an der Front sterben,
auch Mütter, Töchter und Schwestern.
Und es sind ihre Familien, die trauern und leiden.
Ja, aber diese Familien, das haben wir ja schon hundertmal gesagt,
die entscheiden ja nicht über den Fortgang des Krieges und wie wenig die Ukrainer
selbst entscheiden, sieht man jetzt daran an dieser neuen Pressemeldung, die es gab.
In der Ukraine können Reservisten künftig bereits ab einem Alter von 25 statt
bisher 27 Jahren zum Wehrdienst eingezogen werden. Ein entsprechender Eintrag
wurde auf der Parlamentsseite veröffentlicht.
Ausgehend von den Geburtenziffern, also wir sind hier wie im Westen nichts Neues,
wo nochmal der Jahrgang der Neue betrachtet wird.
Ausgehend von den Geburtenziffern Ende der 1990er Jahre könnten damit gut 400.000
weitere Männer zur Verteidigung gegen die russischen Angreifer eingezogen werden.
Für kommende Woche wird außerdem ein Beschluss erwartet, mit dem die Regeln
für eine Mobilmachung verschärft werden.
Selenskyj unterzeichnete zudem ein Gesetz, mit dem die Wehrtauglichkeit angepasst
wird. Künftig gibt es demnach nur noch tauglich und untauglich.
Vormals als bedingt tauglich eingestufte
Männer müssen erneut bei der Musterungskommission vorstellig werden.
Das heißt, die Ukrainer entscheiden nicht, sondern die Regierung Selenskyj entscheidet
gemeinsam mit ihren Verbündeten darüber, wie jetzt gehandelt wird.
Und da spielen die USA und Deutschland schon eine sehr große Rolle, lieber Robert Habeck.
Das macht auch nicht Salinski ganz alleine in Kiew mit sich aus.
Ja, wenn es stimmen würde, was er sagt, nämlich dass alle einfach nur freiwillig
an dem Krieg beteiligt sind, dann hätten wir es im globalen Maßstab maximal
mit Gangkriminalität zu tun.
Kriege wären dann einfach nicht möglich. Und in der Hinsicht ist das eine völlig
fehlgehende Osteransprache.
Ja, die jetzt weit...
Die sich illegitimerweise der Religion bedient. Ja.
Ohne, dass sie das selber nochmal hinterfragt, sondern er macht es einfach.
Ja. Es ist eigentlich...
Weil wir haben ja viel Kritik bekommen für unsere Kritik an Maitis Populismus
Video und ich würde jetzt mal nicht noch hundertmal gerne erfahren,
dass Alice Weidel populistisch ist, also wer das nicht sieht,
dem ist auch nicht mehr zu helfen.
Aber ich würde gerne den Populismus dieser so vernünftig erscheinenden,
den möchte ich gerne erfahren, den möchte ich gerne analysiert bekommen.
Wir sehen uns nach Frieden.
Ja. Aber die ehrliche, die bittere Antwort ist, es wird vermutlich kein rasches
gutes Ende geben, auch wenn wir uns anderes wünschen.
Wir müssen uns auf die Bedrohungslage einstellen, alles andere wäre naiv.
Deshalb sind wir gut beraten, mehr in unsere eigene Sicherheit zu investieren.
Also abgeleitet von der Sache mit der Ukraine wird jetzt gesagt,
wir brauchen generell mehr Aufrüstung und dann kommt er tatsächlich am Ende
nochmal zu der Osterbotschaft zurück.
Zurück zu Ostern 2024 und die österliche Hoffnung auf Frieden,
auf eine erlöste Welt. Ein ewiger Frieden ist eine regulative Idee,
notwendig als eben jene Hoffnung, aber so schwer zu erreichen.
Aber einen echten Frieden, auf ihn können wir hinarbeiten. Und ein echter Frieden
ist ein Frieden in Freiheit.
Das bedeutet, dass es Zeiten geben kann, wo ein Nichthandeln die Bedrohung des
Friedens erhöht und Handeln nötig ist, um Frieden in Freiheit zu schützen.
Die Entscheidungen dafür sind nie leichte Entscheidungen und nie leichtherzig zu treffende.
Und sie müssen sich daran messen lassen, ob sie einem Frieden in Freiheit dienen.
Denn den Frieden eines freien Europas und einer freien Republik zu schützen,
das ist das Ziel der Politik.
Frieden bedeutet Arbeit. Frieden ist eine Aufgabe, die Diplomatie und Aussöhnung
einschließt, aber Naivität ausschließt.
Handeln wir in diesem Sinne, werden wir schutzfähig.
Ihnen und euch gute Ostertage und uns allen die Kraft, in Freiheit zusammenzustehen.
So, ich suche hier gerade mal etwas raus, denn wir haben es ja mit einem Phänomen zu tun.
Es gibt Ryan Broderick, der hat so ein Newsletter, Garbage Day.
Der hatte kürzlich eine Überschrift, all the CEOs want to be podcasters now. Genau.
So, es gab während der Corona-Pandemie wohl so ein Umschwenken der CEOs,
die plötzlich feststellten, achso, mein Business wird gerade hinterfragt oder
sogar auf staatlichen Befehl stillgelegt und meine Belegschaft hängt auch im Homeoffice rum.
Aber ich bin doch eigentlich ein wirkmächtiger Mensch, nur ich sehe das gar nicht.
Ich schicke halt so E-Mails raus, in denen steht, macht mal dieses Projekt und
dann sehe ich gar nicht, wie die dieses Projekt machen, sondern kriege allenfalls
in ein paar Monaten so ein Resultat oder sowas.
Und soll dann einfach glauben, dass sie ganz fleißig daran gearbeitet haben.
Und diese Wirklosigkeit oder dieses Nicht-mehr-Sehen der eigenen Wirkung führte
dazu, dass man seinen eigenen Expressionsbedarf verlagert hat.
Auf Zustimmungsraten, oh, mein YouTube-Video wurde so und so oft runtergeladen
und so weiter. Und ich glaube, daran leiden diese Leute auch.
Warum macht er eine Osteransprache? Er ist der Wirtschaftsminister,
er hat alle Hände voll zu tun. Ja. Und, äh,
Warum dieser Geltungsbedarf? Warum kriegen wir von Habeck die ganze Zeit 10-Minuten-Videos
irgendwie zu irgendwas?
Ja, und meistens zu nicht wirtschaftlichen Themen.
Genau. Das ist ja gar nicht seine Domäne. Es gibt ja, wenn Ostern ist,
die Kirchen sind ja da für Osteransprachen.
Ja, auch den Ton. Und dass Frieden wichtig ist, das versteht sich nur wirklich von selbst.
Also mir müsste man nochmal rechtfertigen, warum ich mir nochmal anhören soll,
dass Frieden wichtig ist. Weil eigentlich versteht sich das von selbst.
Die Argumentation, die er hier macht, ist, Frieden wollen wir alle.
Aber leider geht das jetzt gerade nicht. Also es gab ja dieses tolle Lied von
K.I.Z., das ziemlich untergegangen ist, also es war interessant,
sonst der gesamte Kulturjournalismus, gerade diese Fernsehsendungen,
ich spreche sie hier mal dezidiert an, TTT, Aspekte Kulturzeit,
machen ja sobald irgendwo Campino ein Gedicht vorliest,
machen die ja drei Sondersendungen.
Aber so KJZ völlig verpufft, sagt man so, ach gerade jetzt so eine Kritik an
NATO-Manöver und so, das wollen wir jetzt mal gar nicht hören.
Aber es gibt ja diese ganz wunderbare Zeile in dem KJZ-Video,
in dieser heißt es dann, na klar sind wir für Frieden, aber erst müssen wir gewinnen.
Und das ist natürlich die Logik. Also man sollte sich dieses Habeck-Video ansehen
und danach dieses K.I.Z.-Video oder erst noch die Petra-Bar-Predigt.
Wenn man das dann so alles zusammenhängt, dann ist genau das die Botschaft,
na klar sind wir für Frieden, aber erst müssen wir gewinnen.
Und diese Logik ist wirklich, da sieht man auch, was Popkultur kann.
Wunderbar auf die Spitze getrieben und wird alles noch untermalen von einem Kinderchor.
Also um auch den Sarkasmus mit reinzubringen, mit dem das ja alles so geschieht,
Waffen liefern, damit Lisa Geld für die Kinder hat etc.
Ja, also das ist der Diskurs jetzt gerade. Wir können also schon mal feststellen,
wenn wir jetzt gleich über das Buch von Martin Hecklund reden.
Der Glaube und die Religion sind zurück.
Ja, ich will noch eine kleine Pointe da lassen. Ich habe sie gerade rausgesucht
von Marcel Schütz, Soziologie-Professor.
Er hat hier so einen Snapshot von RTL West mit Campino.
Der seine Professur in Düsseldorf jetzt hat.
Er steht neben Hörsaal 3b oder was auch immer diese Bezeichnung auf der Wand
da ist. Und dann steht in der Bauchbinde Campino.
Und dann, man muss ja in der Bauchbüte irgendwas reinschreiben. So steht hier.
Seine Vorlesung dauert 90 Minuten. Und dann schreibt Marcel Schütze sein Tweet.
Seine Vorlesung dauert 90 Minuten.
Information ist, wenn man trotzdem was draus macht.
Massenmedien verstehen. Und so haben wir es hier auch.
Warum berichtet RTL über die Vorlesung von Campino? Naja, weil es Campino ist.
Ja.
So. Und man braucht irgendeine Information, mit der man rechtfertigt,
weil einfach nur Campino zeigen reicht ja nicht. Man muss ja nochmal kurz.
Schnittbild, Schnitttext. Also führt man die völlig selbstverständliche Information
an, das ist natürlich 90 Minuten.
Man gewinnt ein Informationsgehalt aus nichts. Und jetzt muss man sich fragen,
Osteransprache von Robert Habeck.
Inhaltlich, gibt es irgendeinen Anlass, sie zu reportieren?
Gibt es Neuigkeitswerte? Gibt es Haltungsnoten? Gibt es irgendetwas Überraschendes
oder Sonstiges? Die Antwort ist nein.
Und trotzdem gewinnt man eine Information daraus.
Sie wurde ja gesendet und dann kann sich jeder fragen, was machen die Massenmedien?
Wir müssen die Massenmedien verstehen.
Wir sind hier ganz hin das Licht geführt worden aus einerlei Richtung.
Die Frage ist jetzt, ob der Hägglund uns wieder zurück ins Licht führt.
Das ist die große Frage, die wir heute stellen müssen. Also Martin,
ich bin aus dem Auto eben ausgestiegen und du sagtest, du hast uns ja einen
Marxisten untergejubelt und dann habe ich geantwortet, das wusste ich aber selbst nicht.
Und das stellt sich auch erst mit dem Buch aus. Wir machen das aber gleich jetzt
alles im Salon. Jetzt greift nicht schon alles wieder vorweg.
Nein, ich will nur dem Massenmedien verstehen.
Leute machen sich vielleicht Gedanken, fragen sich, wie wählen Stefan und Wolfgang
eigentlich diese Bücher aus?
Mir kam im März nichts unter, du hattest das vorgeschlagen. Ich dachte mir so,
der Titel ist interessant, weil er schließt ja an unseren Themen an.
Ich hatte dann nochmal gesehen, alternativ gäbe es Der Grund,
ein Buch, wahrscheinlich ein richtiges Sachbuch, so Aufarbeitung über Boden
und seinen Wert in Deutschland irgendwie.
Was ich auch interessant fände, weil das ja anschließt so an die Eigentumsökonomik
Gunnar Heinzern und so weiter mit, was ist das eigentlich alles,
was wir hier als Wirtschaft verstehen? Womit befasst sich der Habeck eigentlich?
Achso, Verbriefung von Realität. Also was ganz Immanentes, zum Beispiel Grund
und Boden beschäftigt uns ja uns am meisten.
Und dann lese ich dieses Buch und denke mir so, ja, das ist schon interessant und so weiter.
Und ich werde auch gleich sagen, was ich besonders interessant fand,
abseits des Titels und so.
Aber so nach 300 Seiten, warum genau lesen wir das eigentlich?
Und dann Seite 301 oder so. Ah.
Und ich dachte wirklich erst,
Du in deinen, ich weiß ja nicht, wo du dich so rumdreist, in welchen Lesekreisen,
es käme so ein Buch runter, wo jemand sagt, hier, lese das doch mal und so.
Weil wir hier wirklich jemanden, der uns Marx noch mal von den vulgären Marxisten
befreien möchte, dargelegt bekommen.
Ja, nein, es war überhaupt nicht so, dass das irgendeine Empfehlung war.
Ich habe mir einfach die Verlagsprogramme angesehen und dachte,
da wir schon so oft darüber geredet haben, dass das Religiöse zurückkehrt,
dass sie ja ein Philosoph ist, der sagt, ja, man kann jetzt nicht die Religion wieder zurückholen.
Es ist auch nicht sinnvoll, aber der Glaube, der ist schon wichtig,
der muss aber jenseits der Religion stattfinden und wir gucken mal,
ob das Buch das eingelöst hat.
Also dieses eine Leben, das ist das Buch, über das wir gemeinsam diskutieren werden im Salon.
Außerdem haben wir dann noch weitere Texte. Ich werde vorstellen den Roman von
Joy Williams, In der Gnade. Außerdem eine sehr opulente große Studie über Hofzwerge.
Und zwar waren das kleinwüchsige Menschen an Fürstenhöfen und das ist so eine
erstaunliche Studie, dass ich ganz begeistert bin.
Außerdem gibt es eine Studie von Informatikern, die haben Popmusik ausgewertet und Rap und all das.
Popmusik und Rap und all das wird immer simpler, die haben sich die Texte angesehen.
Und da wir immer große Erfolge haben, wenn ich über Musik im Salon spreche und
dann immer viele böse E-Mails bekomme, dachte ich, setzen wir diese Reihe doch fort.
Außerdem ein Text zum Thema Informatik an Schulen und dann haben wir noch einen
Text zum Thema Entwicklungshilfe und was da eigentlich schiefläuft.
Das ist ja vollgepackt.
Adam Tooze hat über das deutsch-israelische Verhältnis geschrieben und mal Erklärungsversuche
unternommen, die jenseits von damals gab es einen Holocaust,
uns erklären, warum sich Deutschland so verpflichtet fühlt, an der Seite dieser
neuen Rechtsradikalen zu stehen. Super interessant. Interessant.
Außerdem einer der ersten Versuche der EZB selbst, Inflation neu zu erklären.
Wir haben ja damals zu Anfang des Jahrzehnts schon diese eine Pressekonferenz,
wo von Christine Lagarde gehört, wo sie sagte, Inflation, ja genau,
was ist das eigentlich und so.
Und dann kam sie ja plötzlich und ein Working Paper aus der EZB versucht da mal nachzugehen.
Die Blätter haben nochmal zur Schuldenbremse geschrieben, das gehen wir nur
kurz durch, weil wir im ewigen Kampf gegen dieses dümmste und gefährlichste
Gesetz, das wir haben, immer noch nicht richtig verstehen, warum es das eigentlich
gibt und heute immer noch durchgepforten wird.
Wird in dem Text jetzt auch nicht so bahnbrechend erklärt, aber zumindest kriegen
wir nochmal die Argumente gegen die Schuldenbremse durchstrukturiert.
Und ein Text, auf den ich mich sehr freue,
Andrew Huberman gilt als der große, ich bin ein Neuroscience-Professor in Stanford
und habe da auch, oder in Yale,
in einer der großen Dinge, habe da auch mein eigenes Lab und er tourte ja dann
durch die Podcasts und wurde während Corona der größte Erklärer von allem,
was so ganz immanent biologisch unser Schicksal bestimmt.
Er hält sich nur so gar nicht an seine eigenen Sachen. Und es gab jetzt eine
große Aufklärung von einer Journalistin, die wirklich mal seitenlang,
und da muss man auch echt sagen, ja, das lohnt sich dann auch als Drehbuch zu verkaufen,
darüber schrieb, wie man als größter Erklärer der ...
Sagen wir mal, biologischen Grundlagen unserer sozialen Schicksalshaftigkeit,
wie er eigentlich seine sozialen Beziehungen so organisiert.
Und es könnte nicht weiter auseinanderklaffen. Also es ist wirklich ganz verrückt.
Also das ist dann wie bei Rousseau mit der Pädagogik theoretisch gut,
in der Umsetzung mit dem eigenen Nachwuchs eher schwierig.
Möglicherweise. Also es begegnet uns häufiger, dass es so auseinanderklafft.
Wo man sich denkt, die besten Erklärer der Welt sind praktisch absolut unintelligent.
Hier aber in einem Ausmaß, das mir dann doch zu denken gibt.
Klar stecke ich jetzt auch in meiner Familienbuchphase drin und so,
aber es ist wirklich crazy, was da vor sich geht.
Und Adam Tooze sagt, dass die israelische Regierung rechtsradikal ist oder so zu bezeichnen ist.
Nö, das Rechtsradikal habe ich mir jetzt erstmal ausgeliehen,
wie mittlerweile auch ARD und ZDF darüber reden.
Wirklich? Ja, ja. Ich verfolge es nicht so sehr.
Beim CDF, Michael Bewerunger oder so heißt er, der ist doch mittlerweile ganz
deutlich und spricht von der rechtsradikalen Regierung,
von der man auch Angst haben muss, weil sie das ein oder andere Mal auch Atomwaffenpläne
schmieden gegen die Menschen in Gaza.
Und Adam Tooze.
Und ich meine, es wird ja jetzt auch wieder in Israel demonstriert.
Also in immer größerem Maße jetzt gegen diese Regierung.
Adam2 verwendet jetzt selbst diesen Begriff, glaube ich, nicht oder so eine
Art von Zuschreibung, aber wir wissen ja, dass er der Welt immer so ein bisschen
voraus ist bei der Findung von Problemen, die einer Antwort bedarfen.
Also so wie Adam2 es jetzt darüber schreibt, würde ich sagen,
das wird auch so ein bisschen prägen, wie wir...
2024 FF darüber reden, denn die Zäsur steht ja irgendwie an.
Also sowas wie in Gaza passiert, das kriegt man ein paar Monate irgendwie so
hingebogen, semantisch im Fernsehen, aber irgendwann stößt man damit ja auch an Grenzen.
In der Hinsicht ist das ein ganz zeitdiagnostisch interessanter Text.
Sehr gut. Den Salon kann man ganz einfach hören. Also der Salon ist der Paywall-Inhalt,
um das nochmal ganz klar zu sagen, für diesen Podcast, die 29er.
Oder man kommt sehr einfach an diesen Paywall-Inhalt.
Am einfachsten ist es, man schließt ein Steady-Abo ab.
Das macht man am besten so, indem man auf unsere Homepage geht.
Neue20er.de. Dort ist ein Button, Salon, dann wird man zu Steady geführt.
Ab 2,50 Euro ist man dabei. Wenn man schon bei Patreon ist, dann kann man auch zu Patreon gehen.
Allerdings empfehlen wir Steady. In Steady sind alle Salons,
die je stattgefunden haben, drin.
Auch die Live-Salons sind natürlich überall verfügbar, dann auch bei Patreon.
Aber man hat eigentlich die beste Übersicht über Steady, würden wir sagen.
Wer es ganz bequem mag und dem etwas angeschlagenen Apple-Konzern helfen will,
kann natürlich den Salon auch über Apple buchen.
Da ist es dann aber etwas teurer, da ja bekanntermaßen Apple immer noch 30 Prozent
oder so einsackt für die Zurverfügungstellung dieses Dienstes.
Insofern, Apple ist auch möglich, das darüber zu buchen.
Da ist es dann nur ein Klick. Das geht, glaube ich, dann über den Apple-Shop.
Ich habe ja keine Apple-Geräte.
Also es gibt die Apple-Podcasts-App. Das kriegen wir auch häufig als Frage.
Ja, ich höre euren Podcast über die Apple-Podcasts-App, die also einfach installiert
ist, wenn man ein iPhone kauft.
Wir haben ja diskutiert, ob diese App da wirklich immer schon installiert werden
sollte oder ob man nicht auch Konkurrenz mal die Möglichkeit lässt,
ein bisschen präsenter zu werden.
Man kann auch den billiger gebuchten Steady-Feed in diese Podcast-App eintragen.
Man kann nämlich einfach jeden Podcast in der Podcast-App eintragen.
Man geht einfach oben auf das kleine Plus und sagt, ich möchte einen Podcast per URL hinzufügen.
Ich will ihn nicht suchen über die Bibliothek, die mir Apple Podcasts zur Verfügung
stellt oder sonstiges, sondern ich will einfach, ich habe einen RSS-Feed,
ich will den buchen, kann man da machen.
Aber man kann eben, wenn man eh schon die neue 20er abonniert hat,
dann einfach auf, ah ja, neuer Salon, ach ich muss jetzt gar nicht und so weiter
hier nochmal klicken, da einen Account machen und so weiter,
sondern ich kann einfach bequem abonnieren.
Weil er im normalen Feed im Apple Podcast auftaucht, den Salon buchen,
aber da steht dann eben, bevor man Play klickt,
3,50 Euro, für die ganzen Annehmlichkeiten und dann kauft man den einfach für
3,50 Euro, beziehungsweise man hat ja auch einen Probemonat,
also man kann einen einfach so anklicken, wenn er einem gefällt,
kann man überlegen, ob man den nächsten dann, wenn der Monat rum ist,
für 3,50 Euro bucht oder einfach,
unsere Empfehlung, Steady.
Wir finden das dort gut, wie wir uns betreuen und das ist auch auch akzeptabel,
was das kostet. Bei Apple nicht ganz so, finde ich.
In der Hinsicht, ja, steady für 2,50 Euro, aber bei Apple halt für 3,50 Euro. Dafür mit einem Klick.
Also es ist ganz einfach, wir freuen uns über diese Unterstützung und freuen
uns, wenn wir jetzt gleich im Salon darüber diskutieren, ob wir Gott brauchen,
Religion brauchen oder zumindest an irgendetwas glauben müssen.
Ja, einen Teaser lasse ich noch da. Ich habe ja schon häufiger betont,
dass die Zeitdimension, vernachlässigt wird.
Also es wird ganz viel über die Sache und die Person geredet.
Aber was ist mit der Zeitdimension?
Sachen entwickeln sich. Es macht einen Unterschied, mit wem man redet,
über was man redet und wann man redet.
Bei der Weltenlauf und so weiter.
Und dieses Buch gibt uns zumindest ein paar Stichpunkte zum Thema Zeitdimension. Das stimmt.
In der Hinsicht viel Spaß gleich im Salon mit uns. Kommt mit rüber.